I wish that more people will realize
that if they had an app idea that they
could go and actually build it
themselves.
That's why we created the Android Basics
Nanodegree.  It's a learning path to
take someone from no coding experience,
to building a whole portfolio of basic Android apps.
I'm fairly certain that
anyone can learn program for Android.
I think everyone comes across that that
moment when they're sitting around with
an app and they're like
"oh man I wish it did this".
the difference is kind of acting on it.
It was my opportunity to no longer have
to wish an app existed.
I can just make it myself.
The biggest reason why I hadn't done it
before was it seemed like such a
daunting task to code.
I would say: I wish about maybe 14 years
ago, someone would have told me that.
It's something that anyone can actually learn.
Begin your journey today by taking the
first step to becoming an Android
developer.